TONIGHT"."
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
YOU ARE WATCHING A FREE-SPEECH
CHANNEL.
FOR THE NEXT HOUR, WE WILL SAY
EXACTLY WHAT WE BELIEVE IS TRUE,
PERIOD.
IT STILL AMERICA.
THE FIRST POINT TO MAKE, AND
OBVIOUS POINT THAT HAS NOW BEEN
BANNED AS A THOUGHT CRIME IS
THAT THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT SHOULD NEVER UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCES FAVOR ONE RACE
OF PEOPLE OVER ANY OTHER RACE OF
PEOPLE, PERIOD.
THAT IS IMMORAL.
WE ARE ALL CITIZENS, ALL
HUMAN BEINGS AND ALL CREATED BY
GOD AND ALL EQUAL.
EVERYONE OF US HAS A RIGHT TO
EQUAL TREATMENT BY OUR
GOVERNMENT, IF THE HEART OF
COUNTLESS LAWS PASSED WITH
WELL-DESERVED FANFARE BY OUR
CONGRESS OVER MANY DECADES.
THAT RIGHT IS INSCRIBED ON A
MONUMENT ON OUR NATIONAL MALL TO
THE REVEREND MARTIN LUTHER KING
JR. WHO WOULD BE SHOCKED AND
DISGUSTED IF HE WATCHED
SUSAN RICE ON TELEVISION TODAY.
SUSAN RICE IS JOE BIDEN’S CHIEF
DOMESTIC POLICY ADVISOR IN
CHARGE OF CHANGING OUR COUNTRY
TO CONFORM TO THE ORTHODOXIES OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HOW DO SUSAN RICE PLAN TO DO
THAT?
GOING FORWARD, SHE ANNOUNCED
THIS AFTERNOON "EVERY AGENCY IN
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, THE
GOVERNMENT THAT IS THE LARGEST
AND MOST LAVISHLY FUNDED
ORGANIZATION IN HUMAN HISTORY,
EVERY ONE OF THEM WILL "PLACE
EQUITY AT THE CORE OF ITS POLICY
DESIGN, SPECIFICALLY IN FOR THE
BENEFIT OF MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES."
IT WAS CARRIED LIVE BY NEWS
OUTLETS BUT AS FAR AS WE KNOW,
NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THEM PAUSED
TO ASK WHAT EXACTLY SHE WAS
TALKING ABOUT, AND THEY SHOULD
HAVE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ABOVE
ALL AN ENORMOUS PRINTING PRESS.
IT MANUFACTURES U.S. CURRENCY.
IT DISPENSES TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
ACCORDING TO RICE, MUCH OF THAT
MONEY WILL NOW BE DISTRIBUTED ON
THE BASIS OF EQUITY.
THAT MEANS WE WILL GO TO PEOPLE
THAT POSSESS PRIVILEGE.
WHAT PRECISELY IS PRIVILEGE?
CAN PRIVILEGE BE MEASURED?
IF SO, HOW EXACTLY ARE WE
MEASURING IT?
AND I SEE THE PRIVILEGE FORMULA?
WE SHOULD SEE IT BECAUSE A HUGE
AMOUNT TURNS ON THE DEFINITION
OF THIS WORD.
SOME AMERICANS WON’T GET THE JOB
BECAUSE IT’S BEEN DECIDED THEY
HAVE TOO MUCH PRIVILEGE.
OTHERS WON’T GET INTO COLLEGE OR
GET PROMOTED OR WHEN FEDERAL
CONTRACTS.
OTHERS WILL SEE THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY IN WAYS THEY MAY
NOT LIKE BECAUSE OF THEIR
PRIVILEGE.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT’S NOT
TRUE, BUT IT IS TRUE AND BEFORE
ANY OF THAT HAPPENS, THE REST OF
US DESERVE A CLEAR EXPLANATION
OF WHAT’S GOING ON, WHO IS
GETTING REWARDED, WHO’S GETTING
PUNISHED, AND WHY.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO ASK POLITELY.
WE ARE AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THIS IS OUR GOVERNMENT, SO WE
CAN DEMAND AN ANSWER BUT OF
COURSE THERE ISN’T AN ANSWER,
THAT’S THE POINT.
THEY CAN’T DEFINE PRIVILEGE,
THEY CAN’T TELL US WHO IN A
COUNTRY WITH NO MAJORITY CULTURE
ACTUALLY QUALIFIES AS A
MINORITY.
IF THEY DON’T WANT TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION IN THE FIRST PLACE
AT ALL BECAUSE THEIR VIEWS ARE
INDEFENSIBLE.
THAT’S GENERAL RATHER THAN
PRECISE AND WHY THEY’RE TRYING
TO MAKE US BE QUIET.
YOU SEE THESE EFFORTS ALL AROUND
YOU NOW.
NEVER IN AMERICAN HISTORY HAS
THERE BEEN A PRESS CENSORSHIP
AND AS YOU NOTED AT THE TOP,
FOX NEWS IS THE LAST SIGNIFICANT
MEDIA ORGANIZATION REMAINING IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT ALLOWS ITS
EMPLOYEES TO TELL OBVIOUS TRUTHS
IN PUBLIC.
THE REST OF THEM HAVE BEEN
MUZZLED OR SHUT DOWN COMPLETELY.
THE LAST TO GO A SOCIAL MEDIA
SITE PARLER WHICH WAS CREATED AS
A FREE-SPEECH ALTERNATIVE.
A FEW WEEKS AGO, THOSE VERY SAME
MONOPOLIES PULLED IT RIGHT OFF
THE INTERNET.
PARLER NO LONGER EXISTS.
WHEN THE HISTORY OF THIS PERIOD
IS WRITTEN, THE DESTRUCTION OF
PARLER LOOK AT ITS OWN CHAPTER
AND SO WILL THESE PEOPLE, THE
MINDLESS CORPORATE SHILLS WHO
APPLAUDED ITS DESTRUCTION.
>> PARLER HAS ZERO MODERATION
AND THE WHOLE POINT IS IT’S A
COMPLETELY FREE COMMUNITY THE
YOU CAN SAY WHAT YOU WANT.
IT HAS ATTRACTED VERY HARD RIGHT
CONSERVATIVES, CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, RACISTS, IT’S
GARBAGE.
IFWON BACK THE STUFF ON PARLER’S
REMARKABLE GARBAGE ANNOUNCES
SOME LOW IQ THUG ON TELEVISION,
THEREFORE IT’S TOTALLY FINE,
VIRTUOUS IN FACT FOR AMAZON WEB
SIMPLY UNPLUG IT, TO DESTROY IT
WITH NO DEBATE OR COHERENT
EXPLANATION.
WHY DID AMAZON DO THAT?
IT WASN’T BECAUSE THEY WERE
MORALLY OFFENDED BY PARLER.
THAT CAN’T BE TRUE.
LAST YEAR ACCORDING TO THE GROUP
PARENTS TOGETHER, A TOTAL OF
69 MILLION PHOTOS AND VIDEOS OF
CHILDREN BEING SEXUALLY ABUSED
WERE REPORTED TO THAN NATIONAL
CENTER FOR MISSING AND EXPLOITED
CHILDREN, YET ONLY EIGHT OF
THOSE REPORTS CAME FROM AMAZON
WEB SERVICES WHICH WAS HOSTING
QUITE A FEW OF THEM.
WHY IS THAT?
APPARENTLY, JEFF BEZOS DIDN’T
CONSIDER SEXUAL ABUSE VIDEOS
GARBAGE.
AS A DIRECTOR OF PARENTS
TOGETHER PUT IT, "AMAZON WEB
SERVICES HAS VAST RESOURCES AND
CONTROLS A THIRD OF THE CLOUD
INFRASTRUCTURES AND HAS UPLOADS
AND DOWNLOADS.
THE ABYSMAL FAILURE TO REPORT
ABUSE MEANS THEY’RE NOT LOOKING
FOR IT."
OF COURSE THEY’RE NOT LOOKING
FOR IT.
WE SHOULD ALSO TELL YOU THAT
AMAZON WEB SERVICES PROVIDES
HOSTING SERVICES TO TWITTER AND
IN A LAWSUIT, TWITTER "BENEFITED
AND NEGLECTED TO REMOVE AND
EXPLOIT NATIVE VIDEO FEATURING A
MINOR BOY AND ANOTHER MINOR
WHICH WAS REPEATED THOUSANDS OF
TIMES AND RECEIVED OVER 160,000
VIEWS ON ITS PLATFORM ON
TWITTER.
THE LAWSUIT SAYS THE MINER AND
HIS MOTHER REPEATEDLY ASKED
TWITTER TO TAKE DOWN THE VIDEO,
THE SEX ABUSE VIDEO, BUT TWITTER
REFUSED TO DO SO UNTIL THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
INTERVENED, THAT’S WHAT IT TOOK.
YOU’RE GETTING THE PICTURE.
THERE’S A LOT OF "GARBAGE"
FLOATING AROUND ON AMAZON WEB
SERVICES AND TWITTER BUT NONE OF
IT WOULD JUSTIFY THE SHUTTING
DOWN OF AMAZON WEB SERVICES.
AND YOU SHOULD ALSO KNOW AMAZON
WEB SERVICES PROVIDES WEB
SERVICES FOR THE CIA.
YOU’RE PAYING FOR IT.
AMAZON HAS BILLED DATA CENTERS
IN CHINA.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY THE
HORIZON ADVISORY GROUP, HE RUNS
AN INNOVATION CENTER IN CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA.
WHATEVER IT IS, IT’S NOT A
PROBLEM FOR OUR LEADERS BECAUSE
NO ONE IN THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
IT’S NOT LIKE THEY’RE DANGEROUS
BUT YOU KNOW WHO IS DANGEROUS?
ANY AMERICAN CITIZEN WHO DOESN’T
AGREE WITH MSNBC.
WATCH.
>> THE WHOLE IDEA OF PREVENTION
NEEDS TO BE EXAMINED BY THE NEW
CONGRESS.
WHAT DO I MEAN?
WE STILL DON’T HAVE A DOMESTIC
TERRORISM LAW.
WE STILL DON’T TREAT THIS LIKE
WE DO INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM,
CHANGE THE RELIGION OF SOME OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT ENTER THE
CAPITAL AND YOU’VE GOT VIOLENT
JIHADISTS, THE FBI WITH
UNDERCOVER INFORMANTS,
ELECTRONIC SURVEILLANCE, AGENTS
AND THEIR GROUPS AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE’VE GOT
NOTHING LIKE THAT GOING ON.
>> Tucker: SO THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD CHANGE THE RELIGION OF
THOSE PEOPLE.
THE GOVERNMENT NOW HAS THE RIGHT
TO CHANGE THE RELIGION ACCORDING
TO THE G-MAN ON TV.
THAT’S A BIG CHANGE.
WHEN DID THIS BECOME A
THEOCRACY?
WITH THAT WE WERE ALLOWED TO
BELIEVE ANY RELIGION WE WANTED
TO BELIEVE EVEN ONES THAT
MORNING JOE DOESN’T UNDERSTAND
OR APPROVE OF.
WE IMAGINE THAT WAS THE WHOLE
POINT OF AMERICA, NOT ANYMORE.
EQUITY INCLUSION MEANS THEY
BELIEVE WHAT THEY TELL YOU TO
BELIEVE, PERIOD UNLESS YOU ARE A
TERRORIST AND THEY CAN HURT YOU.
LISTEN TO AMERICA’S NEW BRAND
LISTENER, ADAM SCHIFF OF
CALIFORNIA.
>> WE HAVE BEEN URGING FOR SOME
TIME THAT THE FBI AND DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY RAISE THE
PRIORITY TO DOMESTIC TERRORISM
TO WHITE NATIONALISM BECAUSE IT
THREATENS THE COUNTRY AND WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE SOUNDING THE
ALARM AND MAKE SURE JUST AS WE
DID AFTER 9/11 TO THE THREAT OF
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM.
WE NEED TO GIVE THE SAME
PRIORITY AND URGENCY TO DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
>> Tucker: UP THAT?
VOTE THE WRONG WAY, AND YOU ARE
A JIHADIST.
WE ARE GOING TO TREAT YOU THE
WAY WE TREATED THOSE RADICALS
AFTER 9/11, THE WAY WE TREATED
BIN LADEN.
THIS IS A WAR ON TERROR.
KEEP IN MIND AS YOU LISTEN TO
PEOPLE TALK LIKE THIS AND
ADAM SCHIFF IS FAR FROM THE ONLY
ONE, THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT YOU.
BUT NOBODY SEEMS TO NOTICE OR
CARE.
THE ONE WHO DOES NOTICE OR CARE
IS QUITE A BIT, ONE OF THE ONLY
DEMOCRATS WILLING TO STAND UP
AND OPPOSE THIS TRANSPARENTLY
FASCIST IS TULSI GABBARD, THE
FORMER MEMBER OF CONGRESS FROM
HAWAII.
PUBLISHED A VIDEO MESSAGE TODAY
EXPLAINING EXACTLY WHAT’S AT
STAKE.
>> JOHN BRENNAN, ADAM SCHIFF,
AND ALL THE QUARKS AND BIG TECH
WHO WERE TRYING TO UNDERMINE OUR
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHTS AND TURN OUR COUNTRY INTO
A POLICE STATE WITH KGB STYLE
SURVEILLANCE ARE ALSO DOMESTIC
ENEMIES HAD MUCH MORE POWERFUL
AND THEREFORE DANGEROUS THAN THE
MOB THAT STORM THE CAPITAL.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU JUST HEARD
HER SAY IS TRUE, NO MATTER WHAT
THEY TELL YOU, NO MATTER HOW
MUCH THEY ATTACK THE PERSON WHO
SAID IT, IT’S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.